hello everyone and welcome back to the
2020 Tata Steel masters edition it's a
world champion magnets cross and versus
the winner of the last year's
challengers edition of the Tata Steel
tournament of Ladislav Kovalev and
magnus had a slow start to the
tournament he started with seven rows
but then he got two wins in a row won a
very important one in the video we've
shown well in the last video we've shown
against ali reza Felucia
and now co a live has a has an immense
task in front of him to play the world
champion with the black pieces so
without further ado i'll let's check out
the game magnus opens with d4 we have
Knight to f6 by koroliov c4 with east
six-night to f3 and d5 transposing into
the Queens gambit declined with Knight
to c3 and Bishop to e7 Bishop to g5 by
Magnus with castles and the e3 now now
with h6 pushing the bishop back
Bishop to f4 and now c5 so going going
immediately for the center we have D
captures and c5 by Magnus Bishop
captures and now a3 so all all fairly
standards stuff with Knight to c6 and
now Queen to c2 getting the Queen out of
the way preparing to bring the rook to
d1 we have nice to h5 going after across
and special Bishop to g3 and now there
is one game in the database where d4 was
played but here we have d captaincy for
bicoid and it is as of move 11 that we
have a completely new game
so what what happens next Magnus of
course captures he develops by capturing
now he can just Castle kingside with the
ship back the e7 and Bishop back to a2
now it will be a much safer Square for
the bishop as you were expecting and
when this bishop is developed the rook
is probably coming to c8 so it is useful
to just get the bishop away so we have a
six and now rook to d1 with an attack on
the Queen Queen to a5
and now Bishop the back to be one so
here Magnus is a threatening mate and
you have to figure out how to defend it
and it
a very very important moment in the game
since it's only moved 15 and what would
you play here well you put go g6 or you
could go f5 another idea is to go Quinta
f5 but then then Queen c1 just exposes
the Queen to the bishop and then who
knows what happens next
so here g6 is probably the best way to
defend this although even this weakens
the King side call it haha and the other
hand decided to play f5 and this could
be problematic he puts his pawns on
lights course he still hasn't developed
his light square bishop which means that
you will have problems bringing this
rook into the game it really weakens
well the light the lights words in front
of the king and the Magnus has a very
clear way of how to how to bust open the
position so here Magnus adjust castles
and you could argue that okay maybe I
should keep my King in the center since
this night probably will never capture
as this will give me a semi-open h-file
but Magnus decides to care at the castle
yeah I said that he has enough
compensation to start attacking Knight
captures and g3 with HP after sin g3 in
the now Bishop to f6 putting the bishop
to earth-2 this nice diagonal maybe even
with ideas of capturing on c3 and of
course Magnus just pushes efore he wants
to open up this diagonal and hopefully
checkmate Korolev we have here the
situation on the clock is an hour and 20
minutes for Magnus and 40 minutes for
Kovalev
so after some consideration he plays
Bishop captures in c3 I get rid of one
of the one of the pieces that could very
easily enter the attack and if for
example something like captures captures
happens he can always or even if even if
only the white pawn ends up on on f5
somewhere he can always create a
blockade would rook to f6 so here B
captures on c3 as saying that okay I'm
not really interested in the a3 pawn and
here koroliov probably should go for
Knight to e5 but it's not an easy line
to calculate for example Knight captures
Queen captures
now rook F the e1 getting drunk in front
of the Queen Queen back to f6 and the
now bishop the a to putting
pressure on the spawn here since its
pinned King h7 unpinning and now rook to
d6 again putting pressure here the idea
is just captures on f6 on f5 and after
Queen to e7 you unpin with an attack
against the roof so here probably five
is the way to go and then you sort of
survive the attack and continue playing
in in a worse position but that's one
way to do it
Kolia on the other hand decides he's
gonna go for Queen captures on a3 he
says he his plan is I'm gonna survive
this attack and then I'm gonna have a
nice pawn and start pushing it with he
captures an f5 by Magnus he captures an
f5 and then out rook F the e1 so here
indeed if you can somehow get your
pieces into the game maybe prevent white
from opening up this diagonal you you
definitely will enjoy this extra pawn if
you were able to start pushing it down
the board so here we have Queen back to
a5 now again adding another defender to
the pawn here preparing to bring the
Queen back here at some point you are
now you are going to have to play g6 or
g5 so the Queen from c7 will be will be
guarding the seventh rank so here
Kovalev is already down to twenty-one
minutes on the clock
whereas Magnus is an hour and fifteen
minutes on the clock and there are there
are two ways you could go about it you
could go rogue d6 and then after let's
take Queen c7 bring the Queen to d2 and
continue playing this way but that means
giving up on the plan of using this
diagonal for attack so Magnus decides to
keep keep at it he pushes g4 well not
we're not when the rook is on d6 he
pushes g4 instead he wants to open up
this diagonal and now Queen to c7 and
now if you capture here you can't open
it up right away because if captures
captures then once you lose the light
square bishop could be could be
dangerous for black as black is up upon
so you have to be you have to be careful
so after Queen c7 Magnus just brings a
third attacker to the f7 point well a
fourth attacker if you will Knight to h4
and now our korolev says okay there's no
defending the pawn here we have to
defend with our queen so here we have g5
attacking the
night-night captures an f5 bishop
characters we have G captures an f5 and
now creating a blockade with rook to f6
like we discussed so now it's a very
unlikely that this pawn will be able to
move but there are other nice diagonals
the Magnus can use so we have looked the
east six now again hoping to either
characters and then captures which will
once again open up the diagonal or force
black to deal with this threat so here
we have rook a to f8 and now Magnus
decides for rook captures on f6
basically instantly another idea was
Bishop to a2 just shifting the bishop to
the diagonal where the bishop belongs
and after King th17 quinta e4 and it
will be extremely hard for for black to
make a move but instead after this well
rotate a fade Magnus captured on f6 and
now rook captures an f6 with Bishop to
a2 with check King f8 and now Queen to
d3 probably Magnus didn't want to
overanalyze it as the coil is very low
in time he doesn't want Cove I left to
analyze on Carlson's time so here
Kovalev is 10 minutes on the clock
around 10 minutes on the clock with
Knights the e5 attacking the Queen and
now Queen to e4 again waiting to see
what coil it will do now there is no
darn there isn't all that much to do and
the clock is running so here quite have
played rook to d6 it's the strongest
move recommended by the engine and it's
a it's good that he played it since he's
already under 2 minutes on the clock
so here Magnus has to decide where to go
rook to e1 you don't want to trade of
course or a queen to be for both
auctions have their merits
so if rukh t1 are just threatening to
win the night you don't really have a
good reply to this for example you could
go
Knight of seven but then just Queen e8
check King to g7 and Bishop captures on
f7 and here Magnus just wins for example
if captures you can go rook to e7 so
after rook t1 you can't really move the
knight you're probably gonna have to
play something else
but there's there really isn't anything
else to play if you don't move it you're
gonna lose it so rook to e1
is definitely the move to go Magnus
however decides for Queen to be for
saying that okay this is just as winning
and okay
tink the e7 and now Magnus continues to
wit f6 check of course you want to
remove that one of the defenders of the
rook so of course that's not possible
pink the d7 is played and only now rook
to e1 and here what do you play again
there is not much to do here the knight
is under attack you can't really move it
the bishop nicely slices over the light
square diagonal if you play something
like Knights to d3 to attack the the
Queen and the rook doesn't really work
just to Brooke e7 check you attack the
Queen the king and the Queen King d8 and
now of course you don't capture and
allow captures you just move the Queen
Queen b3 and now there there is no
defense against Queen g8 mate and also
rook captures and c7 just winning the
Queen so here you would probably have to
give up the Queen but you lose either
way
another option after crossings rook to
e1 is to go rook to d2 now the queen
guards the night however now just Queen
e7 check and if King moves then you just
pick up the night and it's not a problem
if some rogue d1 check there are no
tricks as the rook is blocking the the
Queen's influence on the h2 square so
here after rook to e1 we have rook
captures and f6 by Kovalev but that of
course doesn't work and of course all of
you know why but just in case feel free
to pause the video and try to figure out
why rook captures and f6 doesn't work
well I'll give you a couple of seconds
which I had my glass of water here so
for those who were able to do it
congratulations on picking up hanging
pieces and for those of you who just
want to enjoy the show its Queen to d4
with Czech adding another attacker to
the night and here you just lose the
Knights there is no way around it so
here co-ed have played Queen d6 Queen
captures on e5 was played by Magnus
Queen captures rook captures and the now
rook to c6 going after the pawn here but
now koroliov is up upon but he is down a
piece so Magnus just calmly played rook
to e3 and it was in this position
unmoved 36
that vladislav available resigned the
game and Magnus gets his third victory
in a row where as co-ed of still still
unlucky in the standings we're
definitely going to show one more game
in in from round 10 and then we're gonna
discuss discuss the standings as a very
important game is being played by Fabian
Quran and all the rest of Fallujah with
any really a crazy game which will
influence the standings greatly so
ampere of course he resigns his down a
piece there's no point in playing this
against Magnus corbeille who knows that
and of course he resides sure that's the
game I do hope you enjoyed it I'd like
to thank Davila goalie lens sailor stud
Phillip Schweitzer us of butter and lens
Gibbons for contribution to my channel
thank you a lot - really appreciate it
as usual you can check to my previous
video serum thank you for watching and I
will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the type of
Steel twenty20 masters edition checking
up on the Women's World Chess
Championship and of course checking up
on your wonderful suggestions so thank
you all I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day